las gimnastas estadounidenses contra el
fbi más de 90 mujeres reclamaron más de
1000 millones de dólares a la agencia
gubernamental en denuncias dirigidas a
ex agentes por haber entorpecido la
investigación contra el médico deportivo
la reina sar abusador del equipo
nacional de gimnasia así lo manifestó de
forma pública una de las abogadas si las
entidades y los individuos no están
motivados por el amor y lo que es
correcto deben existir consecuencias
para motivar el cambio el fracaso del
fbi tuvo consecuencias devastadoras para
sobrevivientes como ellos no se ocuparán
de ello nosotros lo haremos orgullosa de
estas mujeres el fbi tendrá seis meses
para responder las demandantes se basan
en la ley federal de reclamos por
agravios ésta establece que las personas
lesionadas por negligencia u omisión
estatal deben ser compensadas por el
gobierno en abril 13 gimnastas ya
presentaron reclamos por 130 millones de
dólares
un informe de julio de 2021 del
inspector general del departamento de
justicia reveló errores generalizados y
graves del fbi la agencia ya tenía
conocimiento de las denuncias
permitieron que un abusador de niños
quedara en libertad durante más de un
año esta inacción permitió directamente
que continuara el abuso de nasal chic
ingenio este estado es desde el caso más
grande de abuso sexual en la historia
del deporte estadounidense sin embargo
hace dos semanas el departamento de
justicia dijo que mantenía su decisión
de no presentar cargos contra los
agentes negligentes como la medallista
de oro olímpica simón vice la reina sar
fue condenado a entre 40 y 175 años de
cárcel por abusar a más de 330 jóvenes
ya otros 60 años por pornografía
infantil en condenas emitidas entre
diciembre de 2017 y febrero de 2018